This is how I followed up after my interview to get my job at S'well.
S'well is a reusable water bottle company...
...on a mission to rid the world of single-use plastic bottles.
It's a really great place to work.
I've been there for four years now and I love it.
Once, I had gone in and interviewed and kind of connected with the hiring manager,...
...I left knowing like, OK, I'm going to have to put together a portfolio...
...to kind of show off some of these different skills that they were looking for,...
...be it Photoshop or photography or copywriting.
So, I went home and put myself to task.
I grabbed the one S'well bottle I had and started going around the city...
...and taking pictures, kind of setting up a mini studio in my apartment,...
...taking videos or GIFs of my S'well bottle...
...and sending them to the hiring manager in the hopes that they would land.
I don't think it can ever hurt to express that you're really passionate about it,...
...and you're very eager to learn and very determined to have that job.
And if you have to follow up four times with no answer,...
...then that's what you have to do.
In the end, people are just looking to hire passionate people.
And if you go the extra mile, I think it'll work to your benefit.